the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
well my friends we now have an official
confirmation from hbo
as you all know we have heard a lot of
rumors lately about all the different
shows hbo may have in development
game of thrones was so massively
successful for hbo
they want to continue exploring all the
different stories within george rr
martin's amazing a song of ice and fire
universe
this is something they have been working
on for many years
hbo had five different shows in the
early stages of development before game
of thrones even ended
the first one was about the long night
but that show never got off the ground
the same day we found out the long night
was canceled hbo announced they were
moving forward with another show instead
that is house of the dragon which will
begin filming very soon
they still had three more shows they
were developing but there was radio
silence from hbo
for a long time that left all of us
guessing what these other shows were
about
well some information has finally
started to come out
now before i go any further let me just
show you what was said
this is very good news for fans of a
song of ice and fire
it says game of thrones ended in 2019
but almost everyone knew that wouldn't
be the end
the show was way too successful for hbo
just to sit there so it wasn't a
surprise when they started making house
of the dragon
a series about the targaryen civil war
known as the dance of dragons
like i said filming for house of the
dragon will begin very soon
as of right now the series is still
scheduled to release next year
recently we've learned of several other
game of thrones spin-off shows in
development
including an animated show that is a
drama a show that tells the story of
robert's rebellion against the mad king
aerys targaryen
and an adaptation of the adventures of
duncan egg a series of novellas by
george r martin set in westeros about 90
years before the events of the original
series
all of these new shows are in the early
stages and there's no guarantee we'll
actually see them on screen
in fact there's been no official
confirmation they exist
until now i have discussed all of this
in my recent videos but now hbo has
officially confirmed it
hbo's chief content officer casey bloise
confirmed that the dunkin egg show
is indeed in development and sounded off
on hbo's strategy when it comes to these
spin-off shows overall
he said obviously we know george has
this incredible world with all of this
really rich and complicated history and
all of these characters so we've been
trying to be thoughtful about what are
the stories that are worth telling what
would be exciting
what would fans love dunkin egg is one
of those but not the only one
now what he's basically saying is they
are confirming duncan egg for now
but there are still other things they
are working on as well there will most
likely be more
updates in the near future he goes on to
say in addition to thinking about what
the fans want
hbo will also take into account what the
network and creatives it works with are
most excited about
we'll let the creative dictate where we
end up now
if you did watch one of my recent videos
about these rumors
i said i thought this was interesting
because george rr martin said he didn't
want to make a show about dunkin egg
at least not right now on his not a blog
website george said we're not making
dunkin egg
eventually sure i'd love that and so
would many of you
but i've only written three novellas so
far and there's at least seven or eight
or even more that i want to write
we all know how slow i am and how fast a
television show can move
i don't want to do the same thing that
happened with game of thrones itself
where the show gets ahead of the books
when the day eventually comes and i
finished all my stories of dunkin egg
then we'll do a tv show about them but
that day is still a long ways off
now this makes me wonder why hbo is
moving forward with the idea because
george still hasn't written any more
novellas for dunkin egg
as you just saw he still wants to write
a lot more for the story
i wonder what made them change their
mind maybe hbo is moving ahead anyway
although george doesn't want to or maybe
george gave them the green light
i have no idea hopefully george will
give his own update soon
i really want to know what he thinks
about all of this now as you all know
there have been rumblings about hbo
making a series on robert's rebellion
but this is another show george said he
didn't want to make
right after george said he didn't want
to make dunkin egg he said
we're not doing robert's rebellion
either i know thousands of you want that
but by the time i finish writing a song
of ice and fire
you will know every important thing that
happened in robert's rebellion
there would be no surprises or
revelations left in such a show
just the acting out of conflicts whose
resolutions you already know
that's not a story i want to tell right
now so again
if hbo is moving forward with this show
as well what made them change their mind
i can't help but wonder if george gave
them his blessing
did he sign off on these ideas now he
did say this all the way back in 2017
so who knows maybe he did have a change
of heart i'm sure he will say something
about this eventually
now back to dunkin egg since hbo has now
confirmed it is in the early stages of
development
this could be our next series after
house of the dragon
i don't think i've ever made a video
about dunkin egg before so maybe i will
do that soon
i could make a video explaining what the
series will be about
for those of you that don't know the
stories relate to the adventures of the
hedge knights or duncan the tall
who would become a legendary member of
the kingsguard and his squire
egg who would become king aegon
targaryen the fifth of his name
this story begins when they met over 89
years ago before the events of the main
novels and they might cover all the way
up until they die
now although the story of dunkin egg
happens roughly 90 years before the
events of the main series
there are still some characters we could
see from game of thrones
there are a handful of characters who
were alive all the way back then
for example maester aemon is egg's
brother and if you remember the story
from game of thrones then you would know
the whole reason why maester aemon chose
to go to the wall
was so he wouldn't be used against his
brother egg
[Music]
mother's looking for you
hey another character who was alive back
then was brendan rivers
also known as bloodraven or the
three-eyed raven or the three-eyed crow
maester aemon and bloodraven actually
traveled to the wall together
obviously eamonn became the maester at
castle black
and bloodraven became the lord commander
at castle black
until he went missing out beyond the
wall another character we could see in
dunkin egg is old nan
i have made a video about this before
but when brian stark is looking through
the weirwood net he actually sees old
man and sir duncan kissing out in the
godswood beneath the werewood
sir duncan was known as sir duncan the
tall because he was a very large knight
this is where hodor eventually gets his
size from as well as brienne
we could also see melisandre who was
alive back then
although she hasn't been mentioned in
any other novellas as of yet
walter frey was also alive back then so
he is another character we could see
now there are a few more characters but
i just want to give a few of the notable
examples
let me know what you think about this
confirmation from hbo
are you excited for a series about
dunkin egg or is there something else
you would rather see
i think i would rather have robert's
rebellion but as i've said before
i will watch any show based on a song of
ice and fire so long as it's good of
course
also let me know if you want me to make
a video about the characters dunkin egg
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching my video i hope all of you have
a great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
so
you